know kids are a very strange undertaking
in that there there are a few features
we don't appreciate first of all they
have the the the strange feature that
they are the most fascinating things
that are absolutely not fascinating
fascinating to talk
about so like if I start to tell you
about what my kid did today your eyes
will glaze over but to me it's the most
fascinating thing in the world so it
divides us in a very strange way because
we're so asymmetrically attached
attached to our own children another
feature that I think is really
interesting is that if my kids didn't
absolutely fascinate me it would be the
greatest time sync in the
world but if you have great kids there's
nothing better you can do with your life
so it's really it's important to love
your children